welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm really pleased and excited to
be joined by parol singh who is
currently a software development
consultant for manhattan partners
harold graduated from the university of
manchester in 2018 which is when she
then joined the recruitment industry and
for the past
three years she's been involved actively
in the tech recruitment space
she's extremely passionate about mental
health diversity inclusion she's been on
her own journey on building her brand
and she's even kick-started her own
journey in learning how to code in
2020.
parallel thanks for joining me on the
podcast
thank you so much for having me hisham
um it's a it's a first for this one i've
been listening to your podcast for
um like the last year or two so it's a
bit surreal to come full circle
i'm excited to
talk about your story and i think where
i always like to start
really interested to hear your focus on
this question which is
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant
i know you always ask this to people at
the start and i think people i think
have quite different opinions on it so i
think from my personal perspective where
a lot of my success has come from is
being like genuine with the
relationships that i have built so
i have like hiring managers from like
really well-known companies that i just
literally up like we're friends and like
we'll share like funny like videos and
we're just like hey let's catch up over
like coffee and they always say that it
just feels like so genuine they're the
people that end up like coming to you
and building like the long-term
relationships and if you try to do it
and it's not genuine like people can see
like right through it and i think also
having a really strong set of personal
morals is
so so important because i know that the
industry can sometimes have a bit of a
reputation of being a little bit shady
so
i think if you keep chasing kind of the
short-term wins and you know ignoring
some of like your core morals for that
quick success um i do believe it will be
like short-lived so i would rather miss
out on something small now and to then
build something greater like in the
future
and i think being supportive of people
around you yeah
so building long-term relationships
doing the right thing
knowing what you stand for what what
yeah yeah what you don't stand for and
and sticking by that okay
love that so obviously i don't want to
say this is like going to be slightly
different because i don't think that's
the right thing to say but a couple of
things that me and para really wanted to
to speak about so a bit of context and
para reached out um to me and to just
gave me a just i think back to what
you're saying like you were just really
upfront and honest authentic and you
said look he should listen to the
podcast i've been on a journey myself
with my mental health and other things
that i'd love to be able to share
for people that hopefully it could help
them with their own journey
so
obviously a couple of things that we
really wanted to talk through in this
episode which was one your own journey
with your mental health and how that's
impacted you and then how you've used
that to now obviously be really
passionate about helping others
obviously talk about
um building your brand which is
obviously something a lot of uh modern
day recruiters want to do or know how to
do so talk about your journey with that
because i know that's become a really
strong part of your um
yeah your recruitment desk and what
you're building
and then the other thing is then just to
talk a bit about really focus on
been doing a series recently on like
yeah early on in recruitment so just
uncover like the early days of
recruitment what you went through what
you found difficult
knowing what you know now would you be
different and that's sort of what we're
going to be focusing on today so let's
just start with
i guess like your journey right so
like firstly
how
like i saw that obviously yeah went to
university studied chemistry
yeah yeah i did so what why like how the
hell did you end up in recruitment then
how did that happen i'm gonna say the
same thing
99.99 of people who are in recruitment
say
literally just
panic of being out of uni for like a
couple of months i was like hey chilling
like living my best life and i was like
oh no i'm running out of money and i
need to get a job so i was just mass
applying on like grab jobs and things
and yeah that's where i i ended up like
like a month later um which is which is
quite interesting one thing that a lot
of people actually don't know so i was
like a little anecdote actually i very
almost didn't end up doing it and it
almost ended up being on the first
season of the circle
and so i don't know if you've watched
that before
yeah
so
um well i'm quite glad that i made the
decision that i did yeah i got i got
approached through like social media and
i was like this is not me like at all
like if you follow me on any social
media i'm not like a
not really like big on it and then i
went through kind of like all the stages
and they're like hey like it's a nude
like reality show and i was like i've
got nothing better to do
and then i got the job offer for like
this job and i was like oh dilemma like
what do i do do i go and do this was
like
a reality start so not me
and then yeah i just told them i was
like you know what i'm starting a real
job so i'm not going to be able to do it
but i was thinking ah can win 50k if i
do this
yeah it was quite funny so yeah that was
that was the the crossroads that i was
at like at that point and so that's what
kind of like led me sort of yeah pretty
much getting into them which is funny
how how did you
a lot of people
like obviously you had a very specific
degree so i feel like you would have had
internal pressures maybe even family
pressures of like
you've studied chemistry so like one
you're gonna take that route so like how
did you
how did you deal with the pressures of
like
just what a lot of people experienced
she's like what the hell am i gonna do
in my life like what am i gonna do how
did you process and deal with that
i was i'm just
just one of those people i'm i'm really
stubborn so i was like i'm gonna do this
and i'm gonna give it a damn good go and
i think that's what i've done so i guess
for context i
come from um like a family of like
doctors like my mum and dad are doctors
my brother is a medical student
so i'm the like outlier in the family
like pretty much but
like my mum and dad have always been
they're probably like if anybody's like
listening to this and they've got like
like asian parents and don't know
exactly what i'm talking about like
sometimes they can be really
like no no like why are you doing that
like you should do medicine you should
do dentistry my mum's were always
chilled i explored them but they never
pushed it and it's so cute because like
i always try and explain to them like
what i do
and when i'm trying to like update them
on like my life stuff and job and
they're like yay but we don't know what
that means but yeah no it's it's nice so
i think i'm lucky having like the
supportive family
um alongside to kind of like navigate it
as well because like the first year was
really hard i didn't think i'd have got
through it like without them
yeah that's great that they were
supportive because yeah i've listened to
podcast stories where yeah obviously
people grew up in them and uh in their
in their family and yeah they just like
were like what do you mean you're not
going to be a doctor and that's
obviously really difficult
yeah
right
yeah for sure well um so what i always
like to ask is like what
what skills or experiences recruitment
giving you that you least expected do
you think
oh
that's an interesting one because i
think it was i think a lot of it was
sort of like what i actually
expected to do but i think like
organizational skills as well because i
think i've always been like pretty much
all over the place and
and kind of like go with the flow i call
it like organized chaos which actually
the fact that i got an adhd diagnosis
like a few months ago i was like that
makes sense
and so i think that's definitely like
drastically helpful and i think
being a better listener i've always been
about a good talker good speaker but
then actually learning to
like really listen to people and respond
to what they're saying and absorbing it
and like being able to like read like
body language and things like that
obviously back when we used to do like
proper like face-to-face meetings that's
something that i didn't really expect to
do
love that do you think it's
impacted your confidence at all
i think my i'm not gonna lie i think my
self-confidence took a massive drop
after the first like year and a half
yeah so i think it went
like finish uni like start a job and
then it was like oh no it's not going
well and then i think over like the last
year in a bit or so it's kind of like
going it's kind of like going back up
but that depends on your environment
kind of like how well you're doing
as well because if you keep kind of like
just hitting your head against the wall
and you're like i'm not getting anywhere
with this then yeah your confidence does
take like a little bit of a knock
yeah because
when i've asked a couple of people that
question
one of the things that they've noticed
is yeah like
confident it's like working in
recruitment is giving them a lot more
confidence personally as well as
professionally
yeah definitely okay
so that's interesting we're definitely
going to get on your journey with your
adhd diagnosis because i'm super curious
about that
and i've seen so many more people
open up and talk about
um their adhd journey
so a couple other things so let's just
talk about as you as you'll know and be
fully aware of first-gen recruitment can
be extremely difficult
mm-hmm
what what were some of the the biggest
challenges that you had to work through
overcome
like talk to us a bit about that
i think a lot of it was the
severe lack of like work-life balance
um
like for example i was i'd wake up at i
don't know like six sorry 550 leave at 6
50 and not never really got home before
like seven
you know that was on like a good day and
i was i didn't go to the gym for like
three months i think apart from like
maybe once a week and if you know me now
i pretty much exercise like every day
like really really big on it and that
does like really impact you as well i
think i just became
a really really like miserable a really
miserable person because you feel like
you're trying so hard and you still
don't really know what you're doing if
that makes sense
and so it's that like have you heard the
kind of like the full levels of like
competency by that pyramid
yeah i've if you go through it it will
remind me that it's like competently
incompetent and stuff like that yeah
yeah so like in the beginning it's kind
of like blissfully unaware
of what you don't know so you're like
the first couple of months like great
you're like oh then the new stuff like
this is fun talking to lots of people so
that's like unconsciously incompetent
and then you get to consciously
incompetent and that's a really
difficult phase
where most people are within that i
think like i think it's like 9 to 12
months and that's when people drop out
because they realize like how much they
don't know
and that's when your confidence takes
like a little bit of a dip as well so i
think that's where like one of my
challenges were and i also got put
straight into
a really niche contract market and i was
like
i can't do this and i questioned myself
like a lot and i think that was the
point where i could have literally just
kind of like thrown in the towel and be
like no i'm not doing this but
like i said to you it was like
incredibly stubborn so i'm i'm gonna
find my way because i love working with
people
and see how that was that was one of the
big things i think for me that i really
struggled with
what were some of the things
i guess looking back now
like i totally get that that's like a
really difficult period when you're
fully aware of like what you're not good
at at the moment or what you're trying
to get better at
so like if i'm listening to this right
now and i'm in that period i'm in my
first gym recruitment like what would
your advice be to me
um i think a if you can also seek
professional help if you need it um
there's no shame in
seeing a doctor
therapy i've had cbt therapy
um i take antidepressants and so i mean
i guess just to summarize like my
diagnosis as well so i have um anxiety
and depression and i have a history of
eating disorders and
i'm also having adhd diagnosis from like
a couple of months ago which some people
can class as a mental mental illness um
but even if not then it does directly
impact um anxiety and depression as well
they're known as um what's called the
co-morbidity so they tend to exist in
disharmony with each other
um so yeah so i i'm you know i'm taking
like tablets for it and everything which
i think like massively helps me and i
think like seeking the support of like
people around you it's really surprising
to see how few managers actually have
training in mental health first aid and
i think i don't want to quote the actual
figure but there is a report on mental
health first aid england so people don't
know how to recognize different things
and you don't know if you haven't been
through it firsthand and then if you're
not getting the support that you
actually need from your managers in hr
and like adjustments and things then i
seriously would like there's a line
that you know that you've crossed where
you're like this is causing too much
damage now like there is a difference
between working in a challenging job
which is demanding
and pushing yourself to a breaking point
where your mental health is
deteriorating and it's not worth it
anymore and i think i crossed that line
for a good three months and i was like
in the worst mental state that i have
ever been and i should have left like
much before that and so know when you
have got to that point and know that
that you just deserve better than that
like there's nothing that is worth your
mental health you know like if if you
think about it
like i think quote my boss said was like
don't kill yourself working in a job
where they would replace you before you
were buried so
just something to think about a little
bit of food for thought so professional
help yeah it doesn't matter let's talk
about it more openly something which
looking back now i feel like is really
bizarre
like i had this like manager when i
started and like anything that wasn't
um
oh
can you see me sorry
oh yeah that's okay yeah you came up
with you were saying you had you said
you thought was really bizarre that you
had what sorry
hey
are we back on i think the
collection dropped a second
yeah you're back
yeah will you be able to edit that
yeah that's not a problem okay cool
um
so yeah just looking back i think some
of the things that i did just find like
really bizarre is like
any kind of like non-positivity was like
not allowed so
if you were like and this has been like
you've just started and things are just
like i don't know i'm doing i'm confused
like not getting some good responses you
know if you were just saying like oh you
know what tried to call like loads of
people this afternoon just not really
getting through to anybody so like
frustrating it's like no no don't talk
about that positive mental attitudes but
it's like this is extremely bizarre and
this like
whole sense of like false positivity i
think is actually really damaging i
think we should be able to talk about
like what the challenges are and how you
you can actually like support people so
yeah i think not saying those like false
positivity things like oh don't be
negative oh don't do that why not ask
people why are you feeling that way
what can i is there anything i can do to
support you instead of like oh don't
talk like that you know don't be
negative real positive around here
it doesn't help anybody it doesn't
okay so let's get into this then
yeah right okay you can tell how
passionate you are about it so yes
i love it it's no it's good so
let's get into this because obviously i
asked like if i'm a recruiter struggling
right now in that stage that you
described where you're fully aware that
yeah you're finding things difficult
um yeah as you said conscious
incompetence
obviously we went into so it seems like
what you'll share what you're saying is
that when you was in that period and
when you was going through a lot of
these challenges it coincided with
yeah looking back now your mental health
being affected is that right is that
fair to say
yeah definitely okay so as you said
it seemed like you just literally was
just running non-stop on the treadmill
and then you fell off and you got to
that breaking point right so
thinking so obviously you've had you've
had to go through that pain to realize i
never want to get to that breaking point
again or that line right
so let's just talk about it so knowing
what you know now and going through that
experience
for anyone listening that
like i don't know maybe a pro like may
not be far from approaching that line or
maybe coming up to that line like what
like what were some of the signs maybe
that you were like looking back now you
like you know what if i actually thought
more about that i did more about that
earlier on i may be not would have got
to that breaking point like what were
some of the signs that
maybe yeah you saw or experienced that
maybe you didn't
take action or didn't change anything
out of interest
yeah so i think it's important to know
um and be able to spot your signs for
whether your your mental health and
well-being is deteriorating so or you're
approaching or you're approaching
burnout and so i think some of the
things that i would probably notice
about myself is losing interest in
things i usually enjoy like exercise
reading talking to friends and family
cooking i'm like oh i don't want to do
any of those things
and like obviously like not really like
sleeping sleeping very well i was
regularly using like over-the-counter
sleeping pills
and just to be able to kind of like get
me to sleep it was taking me like an
hour to get to sleep after getting into
bed absolutely exhausted but the mind
was like you said just running like a
treadmill and i was like i just started
to think that was normal and then i
spoke to people like yeah it shouldn't
take you that long to fall asleep and
also
obviously like lack of like self
self-care and things
and you know abusing like drugs and
alcohol that's also like a really big
sign these are things that you can
actually try and spot in other people as
well you know if you've got friends like
look at that look after them too
um and i think they're they're probably
like the main main things that i think i
i like spotted to be honest
um and
it's difficult to say i think a lot of
mine was like environmental i think
there was very little that i could have
done myself without just removing myself
from that environment there's only so
much self-care
um like self like therapy medication and
things that you can do
but if you're in like how many hours of
the day do you spend working or in work
if that place isn't serving you and
they're not changing and they're not
supporting you then just leave there are
places that will actually support you
with like your mental health places that
you feel
safe and that you feel like you
and that's kind of like where i wanted
to come into this because both places
have been like such like a big contrast
so you have to you have to know your
worth and not let yourself get to the
point that i did i went on that way for
three months
like it wasn't great
yeah so okay so let's just talk like i
said my personal opinion is like
obviously you can't i do feel like
personally like you can't point you
can't just point the finger at one thing
i think with this personally yeah you
can't just be like
you can't just be like the environment
is this which is why i feel like this i
feel like
although it's a huge influence i do feel
like as a as an individual you've also
got to do things yourself to try and
give yourself a better chance of feeling
better in that environment but if you do
that work or whatever and like you know
what this every time i enter this
environment or when i get home like i
feel terrible or that's not certainly so
i guess what i wanted to ask you then is
obviously for some people then like that
environment although they may think it's
not serving them or they do think that
it's really
hard for them that what they're noticing
that it could be impacting their mental
health
obviously the immediate reaction isn't
going to be straight away like leave
people right so that's what you can do
yeah well what um so i guess
maybe you can talk about your own
experience but like
what like if i haven't spoken about
anyone that about how i'm feeling right
how do you approach it because i do
think as you said there aren't like
obviously a lot of companies that run
some companies are trying to do
everything they can to understand more
about mental health how they can support
people but it's also a really difficult
place to get more understanding as a
business you know what i mean so i guess
what would your advice be for someone
that like i don't know wants to speak to
people in i don't know where would you
go first if you want to start letting
people know how you felt to try and get
that support and give your environment
and company a chance to support you or
help you because that can be a really
difficult period to try and talk about
it to people
i think a good like step to take i know
a lot of people still kind of either
doing office work and or hybrid so a
good first step to take is take it away
from like the office environment so
and with somebody that isn't necessarily
your line manager but somebody that you
work with and like you're quite close to
so i think in my case um it was one of
my the line manager that i had like just
before i left like we became like really
good friends and like we still text like
regularly so shout out to mike like if
he's listening to this but so he
um if i was like really really
struggling we'd go out for like a coffee
which actually if you understood the
environment and stuff it was not a usual
thing to happen but it was really
important for him to be able to take
that outside of like the office
environment and feel like a little bit
more relaxed talking about it so it's
not the same as like moving into like a
meeting room
um and opening up to somebody that i
think you feel safe with first like if
you're going like straight to a line
manager that maybe you don't see eye to
eye going straight to hr it's not gonna
feel like kind of like natural and the
chances are that person's all also
struggling too
so there is a report and done by mental
health in recruitment which i can share
the link with you if you want to put it
in the description and so study that
shows that 90 of employees in
recruitment have suffered a common
mental health disorder related to work
yeah yeah so
it's yeah like i said if if there's
somebody else that you can actually like
relate to and speak to and like start up
that conversation and i think if we can
normalize it like on my morning meetings
now like i will just say you know what
i'm feeling really anxious today you
know i'm just like i'm not feeling too
great not in like a good head space
um and it opens up the floor for other
people to do so there's always going to
be people that are a bit more
comfortable like i'm obviously
comfortable myself and i'm really
outgoing so if you feel like you're that
person
and you start saying those sorts of
things like other people that maybe a
little bit more like keeping it to
themselves would say do you know what
actually i was feeling the same
yesterday
and so you start and it is just like a
snowball effect but actually getting it
going is the hard part
what about then i think the
the the hard thing as well that some
people may think
and obviously part of it is normalizing
it or feeling like you can talk about it
but if i'm early on in my recruitment
journey
yeah and i'm talking to people about
my mental health that i'm finding it
difficult or whatever but what if i'm
then worried about them taking out in
the in a way of life
they might then think that i i can't do
the job or i'm not resilient enough do
you know what i mean i do feel like
that's also part of the self dialogue is
like if i talk about this so they're
then gonna think that i can't bounce
back as quickly as they want me to and i
don't know what are your thoughts on
that if if i'm saying that to myself
um you know what that is a really
difficult one because i think i only
really started talking about my mental
health
in my current company and obviously like
we're quite small and we're all really
close so i don't have as much of a fear
of somebody
actually saying that so
um to be honest
was you worried about that well what i i
wasn't because of the relationship and
the culture that we have with each other
and it's extremely honest and open and
supportive
yeah so
but i just meant as in like in your
first year when you said you were
struggling would you worry about it i
didn't talk talk i didn't talk yeah it
was part of that reason big yeah was
that because did you think they'd judge
you differently
yeah 100 i think it's like an unspoken
thing like if you think there's like 30
40 people in an office like how many
people are struggling mentally at any
given time and nobody talks about it and
i think the common theme is that you
don't want to come across incapable you
don't want to come across
you know recruitment it's like yeah
let's just do it come on let's just
absolutely like nail this and like yeah
it's just scary
you can't show vulnerability in in any
case in in like some environment so i
feel like that is what actually prevents
people from opening up
that's the that's just what i think this
just makes it so hard
yeah you don't want to
you don't want to be especially when
you're early on right when you're trying
to earn your stripes you're trying to
yeah like do what you're trying to do
and then if you then if you then open up
and then it's not received very well it
could make it even worse
or you then don't get the support that
you get
i guess
like the other thing then that could
happen is what happens then if
obviously you leave the company that
you're in because you feel like the
environment isn't supporting you and you
try to open them up about it get help
and you didn't
like
what am i then saying when i'm
interviewing with other recruitment
companies am i saying that i left
because
yeah i had challenges with my mental
health and i didn't really get support
like i don't know how is that then going
to play out is that going to make it
even more difficult for me to
end up getting more jobs in recruitment
i don't know
i think you can
you can take like the core of what
you've said but just rewed it a little
bit so
like when you're interviewing you can
say that
i am really and like kind of you know
why are you looking to leave your
current company why do you want to work
for us and just say that i'm i'm looking
to work in a company that has a bit more
focus on and you know autonomy and
like flexibility and work-life balance
because that's where i find
like i truly do thrive and it's
important for me to like feel like i
have like a purpose and i'm achieving
everything that i want to be able to
want to be able to achieve so yeah i
think it's you can talk about it but
just maybe in us in a slightly in a
slightly different way because
like we said we should be able to
normalize these conversations but like
you shouldn't also feel like you have to
like disclose anything like drawing like
the interview process so let's say you
know you have like adhd and like
depression if you really wanted to like
i think you should mention it maybe you
know once you're like you've signed your
contracts and stuff and you're kind of
letting them know about things that you
might need like adjustments for and for
example i mean like adhd is a listed
disability so
um for actually failing to support and
give accommodations to that is um a
violation of
the act
to protect it so again something that
people should know
okay
so let's talk about obviously when
obviously we're talking about um
we see your experience early on and then
obviously as we before we start
recording she said you sort of reached a
bit of a crossroads really of like right
is recruitment right for me is it
something i want to carry on with
so i guess
what what made you obviously obviously
the company is going to be a huge factor
but like
what gave you the confidence to give
recruitment another go because i feel
like this is obviously part of
the turnover problem in the recruitment
industry right where yeah young people
can join the industry and then get spa
back out because of loads of different
reasons one of them will be because they
might be burnt out and all these types
of things so yeah what what made you
feel like you're gonna get back up and
stay in the recruitment industry after
your experience which was challenging
towards the end
yeah definitely i mean it's been a good
kind of like like year and a half and it
was really frustrating to see that i
kind of had a lot of the qualities that
people had to actually like succeed in
recruitment something just wasn't right
and
um i do genuinely think that if i hadn't
have ended up with like manhattan
partners um i don't know if i'd still be
in recruitment now um just because it
was that kind of like thing that
actually saved me so
what led to me being here was it was
january 2020 and really get into like a
bit of like a low point and everybody
calls it like you know everyone's
looking for a job in january and i was
like i wouldn't do that and then by the
end of it i was like oh that's me
so i messaged um julie who's one of the
co-founders because we used to be like
friends through friends go and fly
brunches and stuff because she used to
work for the same company i did but our
paths never actually crossed at the same
time um and i remember like one of the
brunches a few months ago and she said
that like she'd set up like
on her own because i was asking her work
was going and she was telling me a bit
about it and i was like oh that sounds
really interesting bit out there
and so that really like stuck with me
and she was the first and only person i
messaged because i was like i can't i
don't want to just join like another
kind of like company like i do just want
to do something a bit different and then
we kind of took things from there and i
met the other co-founders and director
john
um and they didn't know what the plan
was going to look like they'd only been
operating for like just about like a
year or so
didn't even know when they were going to
make like the first hire and
you know it was a massive step going
from like the corporate recruitment
world to joining a startup where i'm
basically employee number one outside of
the founders
and so that was like a massive like
plunge to take but it was extremely
reassuring to me to know how much they
were gonna support me and give me like
all of like the flexibility and autonomy
that i needed so
i mean i
work my i work my own hours i take my
breaks lunch when i want um we've got
like unlimited holidays i don't have
kpis
and our monthly reviews are kind of like
very different so i think what kind of
like monthly monthly reviews always look
like
and so i knew like really early on that
i was making like a suit like a really
good stuff i mean don't get me wrong i
joined right at the start of the
pandemic so everyone was like oh my god
recruitment has fallen apart and yeah i
think everyone was just panicking a
little bit and but you know we did we
did really well like the beginning and
we've been able to like grow from there
so
i'll be honest if i didn't have this
opportunity i was starting to kind of
like lose faith a little bit but on a
positive note i've seen more of these
boutique recruitment companies popping
up you'll have probably noticed it as
well and i think they're really
challenging the way that people think
like
how recruitment actually operates um
challenging those like traditional ways
of working which i think i absolutely
love to say so i think if you're
struggling in like the environment like
the kpis and things like that then give
a smaller company a go because it was
the best decision i ever made
so what what would be like so if i found
myself in that position where
yeah like
i ended up getting in a really yeah an
environment that i didn't want to be in
but i i felt like you know what let's
give recruitment a go what would be in
your like top three would be like the
three to four things on life checklist
that you'd be looking out for that you
hopefully would think would give you a
better chance of being an environment
where you can feel supported your mental
health will obviously have a better
environment to be in a better place more
often like what would be the checklist
you think that people should look out
for maybe i know it's nuanced and
specific to yourself but what comes up
for you of interest like what was in
your head that you really wanted to make
sure this company believed in what they
said what they were going to do that
made you feel safer or more confident
and giving it another go
um so it was one of the things that john
said when we met really early on and he
said our priority will always be our
people obviously we have to be
profitable as a business but we want to
make people so happy that they never
want to leave and that's how i feel
right now like i would as long as like
i'm in recruitment i'm gonna be here so
that rang true um and another thing was
the unlimited holidays mental health
days and sick days so i can't even tell
you like how many holidays i've actually
taken now i think i've probably used
like for what most people is like a
whole year's allowance and i've got you
know i can still take more like the rest
of the year and again it's not it's not
affected like my villain and like my
ability to work and i'm able to take off
time to spend time with family to go on
like holidays or sometimes we just have
a day off to do absolutely nothing which
i think is really nice it'd be great to
see more companies actually i think
holiday allowance and recruitment is
historically it's a little bit lower
than usual isn't it so be nice to see if
not unlimited there may be like a little
bit more so
you know maybe for somebody who wants
that better like work-life balance like
look at those sorts of things but
actually ask about the average people
take because
you know there's there's that you know
people think that if you've got
unlimited people actually take less so
you can actually ask like for an average
and whether they have a minimum as well
so i think that's like quite important
and then like the flexibility around
like remote working um and and like
choosing like your hours and stuff
because i think everybody like works
differently and i work like different
hours like pretty much every day and so
like for me having that flexibility to
sort of like work when you want and
being able to like go out over lunch or
being able to like go to the gym and not
have to worry about going there and back
like over like an hour i think has been
a big contributor to like my mental
health as well it's one of those things
you're not always gonna know until like
you're there but i think there's
definitely
there's definitely signs like those um
where people like like we're adults we
should be treated like adults and if you
can't leave people to work autonomously
then either you know there's something
going wrong or you're not hiring like
the right people like when you give
people the power to do their own thing
like they can do amazing things
so it seems it seems like then to me
like yeah being given an environment
where you do have that autonomy
you can yeah having more flexibility on
if that's holidays if that's when you
work
like not feeling the pressures of like
taking time off
yeah it seems like that that's had a
huge positive impact on your own mental
health so like
why
why why do you think that's sort of
massively helped your mental health
um i think
especially so going back to like having
like adhd which i know was only
diagnosed like a few months ago but i'd
really be struggling with it for like
quite a while so the way that i need to
work is working in like shorter bests
and
like taking breaks so i use like
pomodoro quite a lot which is um if
anybody listening hasn't heard of it
it's a popular time management method
where you do like a chunk of work
usually 25 minutes and then a five
minute break you repeat that four times
and then you take a bit of like a longer
break which might seem counterproductive
because you're breaking like quite a lot
but it works really well for me
it sounds really good yeah
honestly it's absolutely classic you can
get like timers on your phone and
everything and and it's really really
helpful so i i really struggle in an
environment where i'm told exactly what
to do and when so
um a lot of companies have like admin
hours and then core hours so i don't
know if that's the case with some of the
people that you've spoken to as well so
it's like you've got to do calls between
this time and only admin during like
this time
um and it can feel like quite
frustrating because you just feel like
you're being told what to do and i'm not
used to doing that since like being in
school and also i think
a massive source of stress for a lot of
people
is hitting kpis
and even if they're like achievable
but then you're like okay i've done
really well in this area but i haven't
booked enough like client meetings and
you like scrambling to do it and
if you start falling behind
within like the first week or two of the
month and then all that does is
accumulate your stress every day until
you get to the end then you get to your
monthly review and you're like oh no
so yeah
i think not having kpis definitely
really helps targets to work towards
that you decide to gather is great and
but
um
so it seems like then i feel like you've
gone on this whole journey of like just
really understanding
how parallel works best basically i feel
like and you found a
home that enables you to
do that without worrying what your
manager is going to say or like worrying
like you know what i mean i feel like
you've that's what you've you've been on
that sort of self-discovery it seems
like
it's what you've been on and i think
yeah i think it's just such a
it's such a important thing to spend a
lot of time thinking about
in terms of
how do i work best what environment do i
work best in like they're great
questions to ask yourself rather than
like you said like
feeling like probably feeling like when
you was in the previous environment you
just felt like you was always playing
catch up or running up here to like
achieve what you wanted to achieve
so
yeah thank you for sharing that i mean
yeah it seems like you've obviously been
on such an interesting journey on that
so yeah i know they'll be
saying there'll be i know there'll be a
lot of people out there that are
probably in the position that i was in
and you just kind of like really
questioning whether it's for you and
just
like figure out and see like what you
can actually change because if you feel
like you really enjoy it like i
genuinely get so much like joy from this
job i don't have sunday scaries anymore
which i think can be yeah it can be
definitely can it can ruin your whole
sunday you know i don't get that and you
know truly actually like finding like
that purpose and like just like find
your home like find your niche and
do something that you actually enjoy all
day every day because i guess the money
is great
um but if you if you're going to be
unhappy and it's going to cause you a
lot of a lot of stress and effect to
other areas of your life like your
relationships and your friendships then
you can't you no money can't buy that
yeah no absolutely i think i think it's
so easy when you in um recruitment to be
in a certain environment and think that
everyone every other business is the
same
but yeah definitely isn't it isn't the
case
so just to wrap this up then what um
what what resources groups obviously
i've seen obviously you did the first
health um um mental no sorry mental
health first aid of course you did yeah
so like what what resources
could you maybe recommend or groups that
you've been part of that you found to be
really helpful if i'm someone that's on
this on this mental health journey
oh okay so i've got a few i created um i
don't know if you've had a weight clip
before but wakelet is essentially
it's like think pinterest but for
professional stuff so you can build like
different like yeah it's really cool
actually and it's totally free to use
and also i love it because they're a
manchester-based company as well
um which is nice so um i've created a
board on here and which is a collection
of mental health resources and so
there's quite a lot on there so i'll be
happy to share that with you so you can
put it in the description
wait wait clipboards
w-a-k-e-l-e-t
yeah so
i can send you like the link i'm on it
now so yeah i can i can i can share that
with people out yeah that'd be awesome
yeah i know that well dude that'd be a
really good one so i think and like if
you're like a manager or even just
somebody who wants to get training in it
like mental fest they do some really
good anything from half day courses to
two-day courses and that was like
honestly amazing and then i shared
internal training so that's great and if
you're wanting to do i know people
always laugh when you talk about like oh
mental health is struggling do
meditation but it does it does help it
does help i'm not gonna lie i do it
anywhere from one to three times a week
so something i definitely need to
improve on but
i looked at headspace and i was like the
only option is to buy the whole year in
one go which is like 50 pounds you're
like i don't know if i'm actually going
to use it so a really good alternative
is an app called balance
um so that's i know on the apple app
store probably on android as well
they're actually offering a year for
free and it's like headspace but it
actually tailors your meditation and
mindfulness journey based on your
feedback so i actually think it's
amazing
and you don't have to pay yeah which is
fab and then i'll read out like the
titles as well but like i've got a
couple of books which i think have been
amazing so this one is the stress stress
solution okay yeah by um doctor randon
chatterjee so he's the guy he's always
on the telly as well like if you see you
know like this morning and stuffy slab
so my mom gave me this book so my mom's
actually a psychiatrist so
really lucky in that aspect to be fair
and so this book is really good if you
like kind of like struggle like with
your like stress and kind of getting to
the core of um like de-stressing
yourself i think i've read this one like
four times a little bit battered
um and then another one atomic
it's a great reflection of light yeah
it's such a good book so again like if
you want to improve like your mental
health and like well-being um
this is on my list to actually like read
again so if you're really rubbish at
like sticking to your like habits like i
am with meditation in the morning and i
think it's actually it's actually really
good i think the last one that i'd
recommend is happy sexy millionaire by
stephen bartlett have you read this one
i have i listen i listen he's like i
list his podcast every week says is
there a good i've got it on my kindle
the book i've i need to read it
yeah i so i have a kindle but i only buy
fiction books on that if they're
non-fiction and like self-help books i
always buy them in like paperback
because i like to keep them and
highlighting them and like making it
yeah yeah sure
um so there are a couple of like really
really good books that um i would
actually recommend
um and something which i don't know if
many people could actually kind of like
find but i'm basically in a few slack
communities that like specific to tech
so one's a manchester tech slack which
has got a good couple thousand and then
i'm in a smaller like a bit more like a
private one it's like you know if you
invite somebody in and we have a mental
health channel in the second one which i
started um and now people talk about
that like really really openly and it is
the most non-judgmental and supportive
space so whether you do that with work
or something outside of work there is
genuinely like there's not much that can
actually substitute for having a
supportive community around you and most
of these people i've never met they're
basically tech friends so they're mostly
like engineers devops engineers managers
and things
um and if you pop a message on there and
you're really struggling so i asked
about like recommendations for
therapists and people really helping me
and talking about their experiences as
well so it's not like necessarily like
my best friends who like they're amazing
too
but you know these these guys and girls
have been like a massive like pillar of
support to me but you'll find more
resources on the wake up board anyway
i'll share that with you
i love that
well i think um
obviously i know we said we were going
to touch on branding and stuff like that
but i think
i think i know i know how sort of
passionate you are around talking about
mental health and everything else so i i
just wanted to say really appreciate you
being super
honest vulnerable in sharing the
challenges talking about your journey
and
i i mean i'm a i'm a i always try to i
always try to open the conversation
around this because i think it's so
important i've been on my own journey
and i think if any everyone can
just get better or
understanding who they are what works
for them personally professionally
whatever then we can all have a
better chance of taking care of
ourselves or knowing what can give us a
better chance of yeah having more good
days and bad days
and yeah absolutely yeah works such an
important part of that and particularly
in the recruitment world it's it's
bloody time yeah it's a heart yeah it's
such a hard job and yeah i just thought
i'd add as well like if
um you know if like somebody's quite
early on and like you're really
struggling and you just really don't
know like who to talk to like my inbox
is open on linkedin so
like dude obviously i'm not a medical
professional but kind of like been
through it so um you know
start by talking
yeah start by falling
thank you so much
thank you hisham it's been absolutely
like what an experience absolutely love
being on your podcast nervous to listen
to it back though because then you're
like my voice great saw me like a little
bit
alright thank you so much for coming on
thank you thanks for listening everyone